distraught parents
gather at the school compound consoling
one another
as they wait to hear news of their
missing children
ripped sandals and empty beds are all
that remain after attackers raided the
bethel baptist boarding school in
northwest nigeria
while students slept just this morning
at about six i received a phone call
that they have entered the school
kidnappers and all our children are back
including my daughter inside police say
the assailants overpowered security
guards
and took the victims into a nearby
forest
more than two dozen students have been
rescued
this is the region's 10th mass school
kidnapping since december
a day earlier in a separate attack on a
health center north of kaduna city
about a dozen people were abducted
including children
as young as 3. many in northern nigeria
live in poverty
and don't have jobs the region has seen
a rise in kidnappings for ransom in
recent years which is having a
devastating impact on education
in 2014 the world watched in outrage as
boko haram fighters kidnapped 276
schoolgirls from chivox secondary school
president muhammadu buhari has faced
mounting criticism about his
government's struggle to tackle the
crisis
with families calling on the
international community for help
we stand in one voice we condemn
whatever happened
i will protest we'll continue to protest
until our children are brought back
but for this community fear has spread
that no school
anywhere seems safe jillian wolf
al jazeera